the mall manager what's her name again
I'm Nate I'm just an elf wait take your
photo taken with Santa $5 only it's a
discounted prices because it's earlier
in the year okay come
what's going on aboard the bar chords no
take this out
just takes us away let's get out
okay can you stay away from the camera
speed please you can't go in front of
please can you stay away from our camera
person in the cab all okay we're going
to make nine bucks narrow let's go we
are Nathan do you want me to stop him I
said this you want me to stop you
me yeah you've never messed the Santa
Clause have you that's nice let's go all
right James I'm out of the door my
goodness
James come with me
[Music]
okay I know we're on to both we're both
trying to do our square there's kids
around do not swear there's kids around
you can't swear when there's children
around yes I'm walking we're both trying
to do our jobs okay you can't think your
jobs were important than mine stay back
please
after giving amber and Jeremiah their
official uniforms we had our first
employee orientation to go over some
company policies so because of the size
of the company
I'm also the HR department here so we
need to go over the code of conduct when
it comes to relationships in the
workplace because sexual tension is
something that's very distracting in the
workplace if you find yourself attracted
to another employee that also needs to
be disclosed amber do you want to go
first
Wow okay I mean everybody's different so
like for me personally attraction is
more than just I mean who out of the
people you work with are you attracted
to the most including bosses okay I'm
gonna I'll go with you
me yeah so out of everyone you work with
you're most attracted to me right and
you heard that all right yeah I heard
that yeah clear so mine I guess would be
you and Jeremiah I guess no one picked
you but for the record I guess I do need
to know who you are most attracted to
mmm just see her amber yeah okay well
obviously you know she did pick me yeah
so that is unlikely yet happened there
but it's good that I do know that for
the record and I think the fact that
we've talked about it now we can
continue working as peers without there
being any awkwardness okay
do you want to see a magic trick
oh sure do you like magic yeah yeah it's
just low yeah sorry why not okay see the
coin I see you okay
I think I've seen that before okay now
that I had impressed al it was time to
see if I could get her to admit that
there was something more going on with
the best buy price-match policy than
meets the eye one cool thing about Hot
Topic is that you know they're pretty
lacks on the rules you know we can kind
of do what we want a little bit yeah for
example we have this price match policy
sometimes like some will come up with a
legitimate price match and if I'm not
feeling it I'll just be like no you know
what I mean you guys ever do that or oh
I've seen it happen yes that Best Buy
mm-hmm
you've seen what other people not do it
because not do the price match yeah
because they're not feeling the person
oh really
yep it's crazy
yeah and there it was The Smoking Gun
on-camera evidence of a culture of
corruption eroding the insides of one of
America's most respected institutions
but even though I had what I needed I
didn't want to be rude and leave
abruptly so I decided to stay for the
private salsa lesson I had pre arranged
for the day
hola when I started this are you guys
doing you're supposed to move your
shoulders your hips and your arms as
well I have to admit I was a bit nervous
about dancing but once we got going I
discovered I was actually really good at
it look at his eyes
he's waiting for you perfect and once
our day was over we said our goodbyes
nice meeting you okay yeah yeah bye-bye
three sushi chefs
Oh sweetie look open 24 hours what is it
it's like some sort of store but look
for free pizza do you see it it's right
back there it's right there in the back
like any lamp let's go you okay man all
right you better be careful all right
watch your back I can't wait I mean do
you want the pizza or what I've got a
wedged here you broke this you have you
break it you buy it policy using our
intake funnel we load it in over 30
pounds of Roberts product that have been
blended into a thin paste to ensure an
even flow without compromising the
flavor so with that I activated the pump
and it was time to see if this could
work as I had hoped the pump dispensed
the chili at a steady pace which was
good but I realized we had overlooked a
crucial detail the chilly suit prevented
bathroom access and because of its
weight removing it during a game would
not be an option so I experimented with
a design that would allow me to deposit
my excretions directly into custom
rubber underwear connected to a
secondary pumping system so I could
eject it into a toilet via a second tube
down my right arm but once I had some
clothing on I realized the potential for
a costly mix-up was too great so I had
the bottom part of the suit redesigned
with strategic holes in the groin and
buttocks region that would allow the
wearer to
leave him or herself without taking off
the suit but for my plan to work I would
need to be able to sell chili for an
entire game without getting caught so I
decided to start in the upper levels
where security was thinner I moved
through the stadium like a ninja
switching sections after each sale so I
couldn't be trapped at one point I
thought security was on my tail but I
was able to lose the guy by ducking into
a handicap bathroom after which I
reassured to you right now I have it
render my clothes I sold 16 bowls of
delicious chili that night right under
the noses of stadium management and that
meant from this day forward Robert had a
proven method to sell his chili at
Rabobank arena and later that week
posing as a big-time record producer I
opened my doors to the best of what la
had to offer all right let's see what
you got my man sure don't look at the
clock is deceiving everything you also
dependent on perceiving the future
fickle motions of your mind us creatures
of this earth always contemplating time
to a saddening extreme many of us travel
sheep without Shepherds a number but for
battle lon rabble the turnout was better
than I expected and it was clear right
away I was drowning in talent so after
auditioning a drummer named Chris who
could really pound the skins and yannis
a physically attractive singer who had
the right kind of ambition I mean on a
wider perspective like I want the whole
world to hear what I have to say my band
was starting to take shape
this is freedom to me but I still needed
to figure out which musician was best
suited to playing the smoke detector so
I organized the band's first rehearsal
and after watching them jammed
it quickly became clear that the
standout talent was Eddie he was not
only the best musician but also the best
showman if anyone could make the smoke
detector work it was him
so after rehearsal was over I kept Eddie
behind to show him his new instrument I
kept saying I can't play the drums this
is nothing
he's dramatic it is it's a blue smoke
detector no this is gonna be the thing
that separates us from any other band
cookie and that means the guy who plays
it is gonna be the most famous you want
to be famous don't you I was worried
that if his love life remained
unfulfilled he might not have the
confidence he would need to step into
his new role as a hero so I decided to
create an online dating account for
Corey that I populated with photos from
his facebook page I also created some
new images that would help portray Corey
as a sensitive guy that women would be
unable to resist and shortly after
uploading them to his profile it seemed
to work as by the next morning I had a
response from a lovely woman named
Jasmine who seemed like she might be a
good fit for Corey and after telling her
that a camera crew was following me
because I was gonna be performing a
death-defying wire walk she instantly
agreed to go on a date which I sat for
the following night my goal was to
establish a relationship that Corey
would ultimately take over so I tried my
best to portray a realistic but charming
version of the man whose skin I was in
I've just spent most of my time in
Ventura you know really not the greatest
place but it's kind of hard to talk
about myself with a goddess sitting
right in front of me yes or is that a
bit cheesy or no it's actually really
sweet nobody's ever called me that
before I was immediately surprised at
how well the date was going as in these
situations
I'm usually a lot more nervous back in
high school I stood on the debate
Wow so what's it like to debate with you
then pretty good arguer yeah I'm pretty
good at debating should we try to debate
something over I don't know just a silly
joke we don't have to do that and ten
minutes in not only we're Corrie and
Jasmine hitting it off so have you
actually tried walking across a building
at no wow yeah it's gonna be
nerve-racking they also have a lot in
common
do you play sims at all I do it's my
guilty pleasures oh yes it's a guilty
pleasure for me I love sims yeah cool
beans
you